sometimes you're some really good
friends you know for my 36th birthday uh
I came home to find all my friends in my
backyard sitting in a circle unlike
blankets and they literally went around
a circle to tell me how they felt about
me oh my god it was the most magical
moment still to this day of my life and
all of it basically at the end it was
they all just were like we wish you
could see yourself the way we see you
and that's what I try I mean I'm still
not there trust me but like that's I was
even thinking that as you're telling me
this I was like I wish I could digest
what he's saying to me right now and
believe it wholeheartedly but um maybe
as humans we we were not wired to really
do that or some people can and it's
amazing I just I I try to I appreciate
what you're saying I wish I could
believe it about myself for sure do you
love yourself
um you know it's like I think about like
what my legacy would be for my kids and
I think that they would always say like
she was always she always tried her best
and I think that's like all anyone can
do right so I guess I love myself for
that I wish everyone could have what I
had that night I think if everyone could
have that at least once in their adult
life it was you know it was cool too as
my son sat there and watched it all did
you cry oh I was a mess anybody
else cry everyone did cutter cry yeah I
think he did he's not an easy crier but
but I think he did he's not like Jon Jon
Cryer is Jon Cryer no just you know I
always say things like oh I'm gonna go
I got a Christian Bale I gotta get out
of here got what a Jon Cryer
his name's or as verbs I like that Oh
many what was the one that you remember
the most when someone was sitting there
in your backyard that night and telling
you I could see you know it what was the
one that was Nikki who's not like
emotional like doesn't cry she's like
the party girl she's like the fun girl
right
and she looked at me and she's like I
know that you opted out of so many
things because you think you're gonna
slow us down and she's like but if you
could only know that it's like an honor
to hold you up like it would be an honor
to give you a piggyback at Coachella or
a belay or a stagecoach like you always
say like I'm not gonna go I don't want
to slow you guys down and that's the
truth and she's like it would literally
nothing would make me happier than to
throw you on my back and have you
experience that with me and that really
hit me and I just home that was so sweet
it was so sweet mm-hmm so sweet I have
really good friends
I might have embedded all these tears
that I don't do that I mean I cry every
once in a while but